uh because i i didn't actually listen
to the stuff oh god i can hear wade
thanking people
in game hey buddy is it it's push to
talk
i have it set to push to talk what's the
push button
v typically i think hello
oh my god we're going to the farmhouse
the only thing that said recommended for
equipment for the farmhouse was a
thermometer which i happen to have
bought before so i've got a thermometer
you have stuff i played one mission of
this i'll see you in the trailer boys
okay see you there love you
you and me boys you and me boys what
you have beautiful blue eyes
thank you it doesn't look like you're
looking at my eyes it really doesn't
beautiful blue eye well this is
this is off to a terrible
fearful giant yes oh my god oh jesus
christ
hey how's it going a thermometer bend
over boys
optional objectives discover what type
of ghosts we're dealing with
prevent the ghost from hunting with the
crucifix cleanse the area near the
ghosts using smudge sticks
why don't we have a crucifix either was
this a thermometer i just picked it up
and started pretending i'm a doctor so
what do i need like cameras or something
look from the tutorial let's say i was
like these shelves cameras
are handy i don't know what's up the emf
there's an emf detector
that was about to talk about whatever
just got cut off randomly while i was
speaking
talk mark go ahead okay from the
tutorial there's
six steps to detecting ghost and you
need three pieces of evidence
with which to prove that the ghost
exists and you can do that through video
evidence of ghost
orbs writing in the book uh there was
other ones and i didn't get to them
press j go to the last page the the
double arrow and i'll show you the
evidence page and you can see where you
can put in the evidence
yes whoever's got the emf detector it
will go off
but in order to do that log it all five
lights are supposed to be lit
yeah so if you see that light up to like
three or four it does not count as emf
level five
oh i may have just used a camera shot
yeah it's all right probably okay let's
get this ghost
let's go i've never been here i know
nothing about this place or what we're
doing here well it's a house how
different could it be
i turned my shoulder flashlight on and
off or is this all i got a tee
porch i i don't want to cross that
threshold
step take one footstep in there
that's fine what the hell is this place
i don't know how's it going in there
yeah oh yeah it's weird weird i need a
i don't have a flashlight i can't see
nothing we only got the one
[ __ ] flashlight and the what everyone
has a light on their shoulder but it's
not doing nothing
yeah well you have to be like six inches
away from [ __ ] for it to do anything
okay there's a light switch oh there
might be another light switch in this
room
all right cool yeah yep there it is you
guys
thank you a little bit you're kind of
quiet well you're far away
well that makes sense that's really fun
i like it good i'll go upstairs and
check around
okay good luck all right thank you all
right so i'm just gonna be
exploring up here on my own it's kind of
difficult with only the uv
flashlight this is a little spooky
okay nothing up here
there's an axe nothing up here so far
guys
anybody in here oh don't fight me
did the lights go out guys why are all
the lights off in here
the lights went out up here oh mark i
gotta come upstairs
i don't know the lights are out up here
they're not on
yeah no they're out down here well go
check the fuse box
where's the fuse box i don't know it's
uh
there was a diagram oh jesus christ
there was a diagram
in the in the truck that showed like a
little electrical box now i'll go
look at the die i'm going to the truck
deal with the diagram okay
i'll be up here
hear what there was uh there was like
some footsteps up here with me
there's a squeeze oh hi i got the emp
hey buddy hey how you doing um wait is
this is this a walkie-talkie
wait what the hell how'd you do that
apparently b hello
check handy hello
oh my gosh normal oh well that's better
[Music]
i found a room where less than 10
degrees that was one of the objectives
in the van
okay that's good we're at uh when you
come in the door go like
back left but i guess it's all the way
dark where i'm in this room
yeah where where mark's going right now
this room is haunted when the lights all
went out i took out the thermometer and
said
yeah it's four degrees celsius where i
am right now oh that's cold
all right i'm going to put a camera down
in hopes that
something so apparently i have to talk
to my radio and ask the ghost questions
is there anybody here
nothing detective do we know the ghost
name i think we got to learn that
uh might have eyes on the fuse box
checking this
are the lights working again electrical
box outside the door but i couldn't do
anything
oh lights are back on so we can't turn
too many lights on
i don't know about that if it's a timer
thing but the fuse box is in the back of
the house it's a little maze-like to get
back here but it is back here
the ghost name is jennifer white oh how
do you know that
it's written on that whiteboard we have
like a description of the ghost at the
bottom so i have to ask you questions
with the radio guys i i found a bathroom
there's no deodorant
in the bathroom so we're looking for a
stinky goat all right
roger roger that stinky and cold
stinky cold jennifer jennifer jennifer
are you a stinky ghost
please confirm win again all right i'm
going back for it
all right lights are back on guys i
found an axe in case anyone needs to
commit a murder
roger that jennifer if you're watching
right now okay it must be a too many
lights kind of thing because
uh i just turned it back on yeah can we
turn off can we turn them on
real quick and turn some switches up
roger jennifer
white are you there jennifer white
it's currently off the hook yeah but
it's not exactly fast
all right where was the cold room maybe
i need to emf in the cold room
oh what's up emf activity right here by
the foot oh
hello jennifer here jennifer white
jennifer white
jennifer white i sense you
generally jennifer
okay steps from the other part of the
house
are you here have you seen any
fingerprints or anything with the uv
light
no but i wouldn't exactly know what i
was looking for i mean anything you know
anything looks like a semen stain or
just something
no i really know there's been nothing
popping out jennifer white might be
stinky but the
environment is immaculate getting
nothing i got i gotta
the only thing i've got is by the phone
just now could she be like not on
not in the house like outside somewhere
is there another barn or something
i don't know we could check the back
yeah i'm gonna go back picked up this
bone that was on the floor is that good
you picked it up bone good there's
pumpkins they don't seem to be ghost
pumpkins
uh can you confirm that
nope okay which room was the cold room
the
kitchen i believe uh did anyone bring
the journal can they plop that down on
the counter they can write in the
journal
i did but i picked it up i'll put it
down again yeah leave it down and then
maybe we can call out the name oh
i just oh i get really loud heartbeats
what is it oh my god
did you guys get that we're in the
kitchen yeah are you upstairs
downstairs we're right there there's no
emf readings in here two lights of emf
in here
okay jennifer white jennifer white oh
jennifer white
i'm going to check the cameras i put
down the put down the the
i'm gonna go check the orb can you hear
me
do i have to say hi you scared the hell
out of me
oh my lights flickering oh
yeah wait radio radio what was that my
light is flickering
oh
[Music]
i didn't get a picture i freaked out
um
um hey wait what uh
what dude there was a child that walked
in here
he died i don't know i don't know sorry
i didn't mean to yell at you through the
radio
so um do we call the police sean you are
now a ghost
can you hear us oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god where oh my god i
saw her
yeah i saw her she's a little kid she
was right behind wade in the middle of
the kitchen jennifer
are you in here with us
why don't we have lights on jennifer why
did you kill shawn
i'm gonna go try to get the fuse box on
do that do that i'm gonna wander around
on my own and find her ah
okay light should be on try to flip on a
switch in there there's a thing in our
book for murdering a teammate is that
is that a thing i i don't know the signs
are bad
lights are off lights all lights are off
i don't know do we who did someone turn
the kitchen light off i mean i i'm
taking the camera for
anything literally anything
oh phone's ringing phone phone cold spot
by the phone
friends the fuse box is on the lights
just went on in there
we are all close to dead uh you don't
know that
we have a sanity meter on the truck mark
you're down to 14
i'm fine you think that i can't handle
low sanity
bad bad living room everyone else here
why is this camera not working is it
light green is it like green on the
camera yeah
lights green on the camera but i can't
change the camera on the truck okay did
you
hit the mouse yeah i was trying to let
me
let me walk up bob go try it bob you're
going to be on your own for a bit
bob bob oh bob
um where is
where's bob i don't know where bob is i
don't know where bob was
bob was going off on his own he was
trying to get a picture of something is
he gone
wait wait i'm here okay hi welcome back
uh i think you guys are getting absolute
maximum
strength activity at the moment
hello
hello hello
[Music]
bob wait can you hear me
where are you i'm coming in bob i'm like
to the right
from the living room to the right oh
to the right oh my god oh it's wade's
body yeah i hear get in here follow my
voice follow my voice
door there's a closed door i can't open
okay which door
like this one i'm behind i don't know i
don't see a door open doors
these doors are open no wait no it's not
oh you downstairs or upstairs downstairs
okay all right i'm coming i'm coming i'm
coming we're gonna get out of here you
i'm gonna get you out and we're just
gonna run for it okay
yeah i think wade and sean are dead i
think yeah they're they're definitely
dead
okay all right i see you i'm gonna try
to open the door
okay door's open let's go let's just
thank you come here let's we're getting
out of here
let's get bye jennifer see you around
oh my god oh my god that was great good
job
thank you bye see ya oh mark i think we
did it yeah we did it oh yeah we did it
how do we get this thing going yeah
where's the keys to the truck
close the goddamn door oh you got five
oh we're out here
i got one percent sanity i got zero
percent oh baby let's go
let's get out of here are we leaving did
we win
we did it welcome back there's some jobs
ready for you
you guys left me oh hi uh you got in the
van and you just left
well yeah what were we were dead my
ghost body was walking around trying to
help yeah as ghosts
we can walk around and hear you guys oh
i didn't know that
and we could see we could see the creepy
ass girl
oh so you were in the ghost realm
i'm trying to throw [ __ ] at you but it
didn't work i thought you and bob were
dead because she like
she went at you guys oh did she we
didn't even see
yeah yeah no she she like she did some
creepy animation whenever you were
trying to open the door where bob was
she was like in the main yeah
i really wish i could like say stuff on
calms to you while i was dead
oh yeah like through the radio a little
bit that would be great
oh wait are these the pictures that you
guys took yeah those are the pictures
that i panic took
sure those look good they sure look like
do you see the ghosts because there's
totally ghosts oh
yeah definitely man i'm seeing these
wait does these white dots count as orbs
i think those are lamps all right let's
do it boys let's do it
or kill it or whatever yeah we're
investigating the ghost of tanglewood
street house i did add a crucifix this
car this time just in case
okay sounds good oh wait do i have to
like add my at my flashlight
yeah yeah you have to add click add then
yeah the plus okay we got four
flashlights in here now so mine's in
there
i see three out of four but i'll trust
you i see four out of five is four out
of four
okay cool oh thank god
i think this is the same as the uh
tutorial house please don't have smudge
sticks but we can please don't
we can use the crucifix wait thermometer
that wasn't recommended for this one
wait i think it's universal like you
need a smudge stick you need
crucifix you need the thermometer like
but these are optional objectives these
are not the main ones
that's true the main one is just proving
that it's real and it gives you the
basic stuff for that
we're looking for something smudgies and
thermometers okay lisa what
lisa white jennifer's sister sounds good
let's go nerd
all right nerds
okay it says you should be able to anger
and get some paranormal activity by
talking to it
lisa white red leather yellow leather
the rain is so
loud guys yeah let's get inside i'm
getting soaked
i need to yell talk to lisa white i need
to be on like a specific frequency do i
just turn it on and keep
i think you just sit just go into a room
and talk for a few well bouncing between
frequencies maybe i don't know
let's all just like circle up and and
listen to him talk to her okay sounds
good so when the flashlight's not in
your hand you can press t and now it
goes up on your shoulder
what oh that's really useful oh i don't
have the flashlight you could just have
a better flashlight on your shoulder
no you can have two items
it doesn't quite work that way lisa
white
are you here
lisa white nothing detected okay
this room's clear boys why are you so
scared
we need to stay together because she
gets angry at that she hates people
sticking together oh wait
am i supposed to place this camera down
only in the room that she's in okay so i
carry it around till we figure out where
she might be
lisa white are you here nothing to take
okay all right that's why everyone fuse
boxes in the garage
all right where's the garage what's up
right over here okay gotcha
gotcha i got some activity over here
where why
are you guys not hearing that i heard
that is the green light on
yeah yeah it's gone what was that
something's talking it's on my radio
lisa white
lisa talk to us what are you saying
we're here to help or kill you
oh it's just like death say f death
lisa we're not here to kill you i
changed my mind
please lisa white lisa if you're here
give us a sign
i see nothing on the camera right now
does that count as a spirit box
thing because i'm writing that down in
our evidence yeah
sure okay so we also got emf here write
that down uh
wade confirmed nothing on camera nothing
on camera just you guys
all right i'm gonna place down the book
of the camera oh so i found a key on
that thing and it let me pick it up
uh book is down by the way you guys
knock this over
lisa white please write in the i may
have
lisa
[Music]
lisa white are you an adult or a child
kill lisa white lisa who did you kill
oh there's writing there's writing
there's writing can't run
lisa why can't you run
lisa why do you need an adult all right
let's just get back to the truck
let's head back to the truck yeah let's
document what we found
we have ghost riding in spirit box we
don't know if it's cold
no no orbs yet mark did you say
fingerprints right here
no i didn't see you right yeah
fingerprints but i can look closer
for a spirit box i don't know i mean
someone talked
i'm gonna go back real quick i'm gonna
look for fingerprints if i see any if i
don't
answer the radio in a few minutes uh i'm
dead
are you seeing anything on the camera
can you guys hear me at all
okay all right
oh it did fall okay is that an evidence
moving objects i don't know
there's a lot of noises in here we need
to check for fingerprints we need to
check for fingerprints i'm going to go
with
who is the fingerprint scanner i do i'm
looking for it right now that's what i'm
trying to see but i'm not seeing
anything and i don't exactly know what
exactly it would be
wait everyone turn off your lights and
set the lights out to be off to get
activity on the box
lisa white give us a sign
lisa white why were you killed
i keep hearing stuff but i don't know
what it's saying i think it said attack
is that what it says that's not what i'm
hearing adult
adult death i thought it said milf
lisa white are you a milf wait anything
on the camera
no there's nothing interesting happening
i was looking at my journal
uh the more people are nearby the more
active an oni is
then you need to come in here we need
all four of us what was the last
possibility spirit spirit is very hard
we have to find fingerprints
there are no fingerprints oh my god this
lamp in the children's room is from
house flipper sim
is this game based on house flipper uh
possibly she's still around this dining
room table
let's all gather up and try talking to
her lisa white are you here
ems is no longer going off in here kill
kill lisa white are you angry
yes what
[Music]
[Applause]
it just said hey in my ear okay so we're
grouped up and she's getting more pissed
off
i got emf up to four over here lisa why
lisa white how did you die
she's back to the table
lisa white are you here
what what was that catch kids catch
oh god lisa white what am i catching oh
adult attack lisa why are you attacking
us
show yourself lisa why were you murdered
lisa white i am an adult come attack me
she is like in sean
yeah she loves me i don't know if i like
being radio guy anymore
lisa white lisa white lisa white wait
that's moving
that cup just moved wait what oh the cup
just moved into the book lisa white are
you a cup
lisa white lisa white lisa white lisa
white
lisa white lisa white spammer named lisa
lisa white lisa white he's a white white
lisa white lisa
mr white lisa white lisa white oh my god
i just saw her
i saw her she went out that hallway she
went over this way i didn't saw her
lisa white lisa white lisa white oh
she's downstairs
she's coming upstairs oh my god oh she's
chasing me
cruising back squishy mix
where is it oh
sean's dead found the flashlight on me
why don't i have it shawn's dead why
don't i have the crucifix
i lost the crucifix i don't have the
crucifix where'd it go i'm gonna go turn
on the lights
hey lisa killed my friend
lights on or off guys where's the
crucifix i lost the crew
in here she just moved
i don't see the crucifix well honestly
what more do we need to get
yeah i mean do we have what we need to
get rid of her is it our job to get rid
of her
my flashlight is flashing too she's
coming she's coming
oh no from the basement from the
basement
[Music]
she's sled lisa go away lisa lisa you go
to your room lisa you're working
out he's a good hero
i did i think i like splashing yeah i
think what happened
oh god the door was locked i don't think
i had the key oh god
oh okay all right good job guys good
hunt well done
oh our sanity was non-existent
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait i'll
just i'm gonna guess please please
yeah just ah
the ghost was a spirit wow thanks guys
she was just a tiny little girl
she had a really long neck yeah well it
was like a little baby walking around
but holy geez that's
a lot yeah okay so we need we should
have tried to guess what she was before
we went back just putting a guess and
probably would have
i put in a guess but it was a it was a
spirit definitely but hey 10 bucks
that's
that's money i got a bunch of money i
got 65 bucks now whatever
you got 65 bucks
i'm gonna buy some smudge sticks i guess
oh wait no no i just i just bought
sponge sticks i just buy a thermometer
if you can
we probably need more than one don't we
probably
honestly probably i also really like
that as soon as we start saying her name
more and more she got pissed and killed
me
that's cool she didn't you guys might
need to re-add your flashlights
so we've got three flashlights we're
still missing one did everyone add their
flashlight back i see four of four again
we've i see four okay all right i'll
trust you guys then we've only got one
smudge stick but that's probably okay we
haven't even had any before
watch them do we need to light those do
we need a lighter for those i don't know
i don't know what a smudge stick even is
it's like one of those like it looks
like a cigar and i i think you light it
on fire and you like if you like use
this smoke to like cleanse the room
no it's when it's attacking you you burn
it yeah and it will prevent
you from dying burning much like there
it goes
from attacking for a period of time it's
just to protect us that's what i said
you know no one believes me
all right we're going to edge field
street house we're going to have a
successful ghost hunt
okay this is going to be the one okay
this is the one this is the one
we're all gonna die okay so we need to
say karen martin a bunch to get some
activity and then start documenting the
[ __ ]
i got the emf reader so evidence with
the emf reader i can do that
cleanse with smudge sticks we have this
thermometer we can do all these
yep sounds good the fuse box is very
back left the door is in the
oh no oh there's three floors we going
boys yeah we're going for it i've
already got three items so i couldn't
care anymore
karen karen god that lovely
karen martin uh fyi
fuse boxes in the garage again all right
i'm gonna check for temperatures
i've got no emf readings upstairs i'm
going all the way to the basement
okay upstairs
hello karen martin says nothing detected
is that good
karen martin show yourself i no longer
have any readings in here
okay karen i like your kids lofted bed
with a desk under it that's a nice
choice you're really maximizing the
space in that room
it's unfortunate that your youngster has
to share a bedroom with the with the
baby though that's
what are you cheaping out on your kids
there maybe that's why she died did your
kids kill you for making them share a
bedroom karen
okay i'm getting like all regular
temperatures up here
yeah i'm not seeing anything i'm no
longer getting an emf
up here i think we shamed her did you
leave your iphone 7 not plugged in on
your nightstand because you're a
boomer karen i probably shouldn't be
wandering on my own
or if i can scare them sean and i are in
the basement
oh you're right here hey karen
hey karen your basement's a mess
all right what are you doing considering
how organized your best friend was
karen i thought you were possessed oh no
is that a thing that can happen
are you karen are you karen maybe we're
all karen inside
oh my god guys i picked up a hammer oh
yeah you can pick up random tools for
some reason
you hearing that wait watch out you
heard that
is that you coming down the stairs no no
it's like a groaning like i was like
oh no that's in here there's something
going on maybe that's upstairs
there's no floorboards in here to make
that sound mrs martin
miss martin ma'am are we are we not
getting any emf either like we get
nothing here
not just the three dots i got upstairs
uh maybe we should go back upstairs
why do your washer and dryer look like
they've been through a tornado
cell phone cell phone ringing
that sounded very close to me yeah what
was that
that was a there's a cell phone in the
master bedroom upstairs
well i didn't hear anything i hear a car
the car was going off oh that was me
that was i was beeping that
why are these drawers open give us a
sign did someone do this
i did that give us a sign karen
karen martin are you oh adult she said
adult
karen martin are you a child okay
we have spiritual hearings karen talk to
me
heard it she said are you dead i put
some salt down at the front door so if
she walks in we'll know
karen martin are you in here can we walk
over the salt without triggering it
i will let you know yep thank you for
seasoning the floor
what did she say what'd you say guy die
die
karen martin why did you die how did you
die i don't think you should be saying
the name so much
every time i did that daryn martin karen
martin karen martin karen mark
uh we're [ __ ] mark are you going to
the town uh no i'm on the bed
oh who stepped okay i'm gonna run to the
camera real quick i played the camera
i'll be right back maybe don't
say the name maybe don't say the name
before you ask the question maybe just
ask the question
why are you a ghost
wait who opened that are we pissing you
off are you mad who's
who's opening and closing doors
uh i heard a door open oh i heard a door
for a handprint
karen would you say you're a boomer oh i
heard a door again oh there's another
hand print
oh bad bad bad bad
i'm i don't like this i haven't seen any
objects do we have a situation
wait is objects thrown uh uh uh on
evidence
oh we're good we're good we're good i'm
moving the camera i'm moving the camera
in the last house there were so many
objects thrown but that wasn't one of
the options based on our other evidence
oh okay i put the camera in the bedroom
where the actual
yeah i put salt down uh no foot steps
through it though
i i think it's got to be this room up
here with all the hand prints
that just seems like obvious parker
uh no
yeah you're hearing that right i'm
definitely hearing that oh there's
another hand print on this
or maybe it was always on there might
have been just
it closed
oh it's just closing every time i open
it oh my god
uh can we get some eyes up in this bed
it's in the closet i think it's hiding
in the closet
oh no it's not hiding anymore oh no
bad bad bad bad bad we can't get out we
can't get up
wow i see it
i can't open the door won't open oh okay
okay we're getting we're leaving hey
guess what guys yeah we saw it there's a
ghost in here what's up
yeah we totally found it yep mystery
solved all right let's go
well that's a job well done my dude
my flashlight's flickering is that good
yeah it's fine
we're probably safe out here right now
we're fine out here oh my god look at
the activity
graph yeah that's a lot of activity oh
you can see them on the map in there oh
you can see where they are
yes
dead uh what
uh
i think it's a wraith wait we should
salvage what's on wade's body though
oh yeah you're right you're right uh
good luck
this is scary they're so dead
they're dead all right i got the emf and
the smudge stick that way
okay so we know what type of ghost it is
how do we banish it
uh do we need to banish it is that our
job i think you gotta
call out what it is right it's a wraith
right so what is our evidence we had
spirit box we had fingerprints and then
we had
temperature did no one bring the german
emf wait did no one bring the journal in
i was bringing it back in and then it
killed wade oh okay uh
well so we just identify it right but
how do we like finish the mission
well i think we just leave it says the
bomb some missions only complete when
you leave
so are we confident it's a wraith well
did you get temperature readings
i didn't get any low ones but it's like
the only thing
left that i can imagine wraith is one of
the most dangerous ghosts it's
uh also the only known ghost that has
the ability of flight and has sometimes
been known to travel through walls
race almost never touched the ground
meaning it can't be tracked by footsteps
oh but you had the salt down we were not
getting footprints so yeah
okay it has to be a wraith then right uh
makes sense to me but i didn't get any
temperatures i can go put the journal
down do you guys want me to do that
i don't all right i'll be back maybe
once we get the camera okay sounds good
just get the camera you want me to get
the camera and do all the other stuff
and figure out what kind of [ __ ] it
well i'm fine
i'm fine i'm not fine
i'm not fine i'm not fine i'm going i'm
going i'm going i'm going i'm leaving
i'm leaving i'm leaving i'm leaving i'm
leaving i'm leaving i'm leaving i'm
leaving i'm leaving i'm leaving
hey
[Music]